[Music]
oh hello
technology isn't just changing our lives
it's changing our brains not just how
they think
but how they look it's been shown that
playing certain video games for hours
can improve your memory for details your
ability to navigate space
in video games and can make your brain
well certain parts of it bigger but
scientists want to know if exploring
digital worlds
can change our brains in ways that
improve our ability
to navigate the real world to find out
we've built a giant maze to test their
theories
for the first time ever outside the
world of computers
now my job i'm
the lab rat
[Music]
our brains have been profoundly
transformed by our interactions with
technology
a lot of the information that i used to
have to store in my brain
is now stored in my phone my contacts
my schedule in many ways i've delegated
what used to be done by this organ
to this new external organ
doing that frees up my brain's resources
for other things that matter or
that technology can't quite do for us
yet so
while we all don't have implants in our
brains yet
technology has already found a way into
our heads
which is why you may find it deeply
disturbing to see me do something
like this
studies show we can improve our brains
by having enriching experiences
like playing a new challenging video
game to learn more about this
i came to uc irvine's stark lab to speak
with experts in the field of learning
and memory
so dane and craig you guys work on
learning and memory
what about them so the lab is trying to
figure out how memory works
how it works in the brain and one brain
structure
in the temporal lobe that we know is
important to memory is
the hippocampus so what does the
hippocampus
do we know it has a role in memory and
really a
a certain kind of memory the hippocampus
is really involved when you need to
rapidly form new arbitrary associations
you know remembering what you did
yesterday definitely needs the
hippocampus
maybe we'll go to the store we park our
car in the lot and we need to be able to
remember
not just i parked my car in the lot i
parked my car in this exact spot
in the lot right and those details
that's what the hippocampus seems to
really be
helping us out on now you keep looking
down at this piece of chewed bubble gum
on the book
is that a hippocampus yes this actually
is my hippocampus
is this the whole thing or is it
symmetric oh there's one on the other
side that looks just like this
yeah mirror image i've had in 2015 dr
stark and dr clemenson conducted a study
to show how video games affect the brain
they gathered participants who normally
didn't play video games and split them
up into three groups
a control group who didn't play any
video games for two weeks
an active control group who played
two-dimensional games for two weeks
and an experimental group who played 3d
games for two weeks
beforehand they had all the participants
perform two virtual tasks on computers
to measure their spatial memory
as soon as they came back we
readministered those two tasks and what
we found was that the people who played
the 3d game saw an improvement in their
test scores
whereas the control group and the active
control group did not
we didn't do brain scans but we can
speculate that there were changes to the
experimental group's hippocampi
so what are we going to be doing to me
here
so we're going to do everything that
we've done before in our past studies
except we're going to add two new things
the first is we're going to add some
brain scans to see if we see a change in
the structural side of your hippocampus
i mean we've never actually looked at
somebody's rain scans before and after
they play video games
and the second thing we're actually
going to do is we're going to put you
through a real world space
you're going to be the rat in a maze
this is truly untested territory
the effect of video gaming on spatial
memory has never been studied in a
physical environment on a scale this big
and comprehensive i will have to
navigate my way through a 3600 square
foot physical maze will playing video
games improve my mental skills
in the real world if so society will
have a whole new way
to look at gaming first we had to get
baseline measurements of my brain
welcome to the mri center we're going to
be taking a whole series of scans of you
as the before scan to then see what's
going to be happening to your brain as a
function of actually doing the gaming
cool what kind of things are you looking
for changes in the size and shape of
your hippocampus and also changes in the
connectivity between brain regions my
brain was scanned using
diffusion mri with a special emphasis on
my all-important
hippocampus
so this first test is a standard memory
test that we do it's called an object
recognition
memory test this test began by showing
me a series of random objects
i did my best to commit every one of
them to memory
okay finished all right what we're going
to do now though is we're going to test
your memory
for those objects okay and this is
actually where it starts to tap
into the hippocampus that we know is so
important for things like spatial memory
this time i had to view another series
of objects and identify any that were
identical to the ones i'd seen
previously the catch some of the items
were very similar to the earlier ones
but not
exactly the same this tested my memory
for details
and very slight changes okay next up
a virtual version of a water maze
normally used by rodents
the idea is that you are trying to
locate a hidden platform
in a pool of water oh man i'm so glad
i'm not a
lab rap this task really put my spatial
memory to the
test i had to find the same invisible
underwater platform
over and over again using only the
shapes of the mountains as my guide
but at least i didn't have to get wet
hey
that was more difficult than i expected
these are the sorts of tasks that we've
been able to do
because we can put them on a computer
and we're going to revisit them
after you've done the video games but we
also have a
really great opportunity here now to be
able to try to take it out of just doing
it on the computer and actually get it
into the
real world have you guys done this
before no we don't get to do this kind
of thing well welcome to the minefield
awesome
so this is it it's huge this is what we
brought you here for to have a real
world test of memory
you're going to be a lab rat in a maze
so this is a big first for us it's a big
first really for memory research
so how do you think that'll affect what
you guys have already seen which is that
moving around in a 3d environment in the
video game can
actually physically affect your brain we
would expect that if we can somehow kind
of train your hippocampus to be better
at spatial memory and spatial navigation
we would see improvements in some of
these areas and it's not just going to
be running a maze
you've got objects embedded inside here
and we're going to be testing your
ability to remember where everything
is and build a mental map of whatever is
inside there
so you have five minutes go on in
explore learn the maze and learn the
objects
go because the walls were six
feet tall i was unable to get a bird's
eye view
my task was to create a spatial memory
based entirely on the angles and turns
of the white walls i could see at eye
level and a few tall trees and light
poles outside the maze
okay so i've oriented myself the
entrance is that way there's an exit
over there
i'm considering this the right side that
the left side i've got a vague idea of
where things are that i feel like
exist along the outside edge but i don't
know about a lot of the stuff inside
and time all right so now you've had a
chance to explore the maze find out
where the objects are
now we're going to test your memory okay
and we'll be timing you and seeing where
you go
okay okay you ready i'm ready so your
first object is the bicycle pump
go pump okay
pump was just always making right turns
hugging
the rightmost part of pomp
yes easy okay now i guess i do the
opposite to get out
left side i yep i think i should make
this turn
there it is
yes for a pump all right item two the
basketball
later dr stark and dr clemenson would
evaluate my performance on how fast i
was
the number of errors i made and whether
i took the most optimal route each time
and time third item is the cat go
here kitty kitty kitty got it
the fourth item is the pillow retracing
my steps
the crayon easy the book okay the boot
last item is the water bottle go water
bottle
i think if i
yeah it was back here
maybe on the other side of this wall
no oh okay maybe it's down here
oh wait that's no
that's the central cube it was down some
sort of
a long corridor like this in this area
until this point things had gone pretty
well but now it felt like my hippocampus
was failing me
with most of the items now gone i
couldn't use them for reference and it
was difficult to distinguish the
differences between the various white
corridors ah dang it
oh what about through got it
bottle coming up all right there you go
got it that one was a little tougher huh
yeah that was tougher so we found all
eight objects yep now we're gonna make
it a little bit more difficult so we're
gonna move on to the next phase and
that's gonna be from the other side
navigating the maze in reverse will be
an even bigger test of your spatial
memory
we're going to give you a list of four
things to get
in order so the first sequence is the
book the bottle
the crayon and the boot go book
i think that's the ball
got it uh yeah a bottle was that hard
one but now
i remember which alley to go down
perfect
crayon ah boot don't want that
there it is okay now i need the boot
oh i just saw the boot but how did i
got it i'm done i'm coming back
got him all right so then the next four
the pump
the pillow the basketball and the cat
all right nice job
okay so that was really fun but i can't
be the only subject
this experiment could use a control how
else will we know that
me enriching my life with daily video
game playing
really causes a change in my spatial
memory right well
luckily for that we've got a nice
matched control
guys similar to me okay one of them has
too much hair but you guys look good
you ready ready in this experiment it
was important to have a control group
my lookalikes had to go through the
exact same tests that i did to establish
their individual baselines
the difference would be that they would
play absolutely no video games for the
next
10 days then any change in my
performance would be compared against
any changes
in theirs
next i began my gaming regimen starting
from an ideal baseline since i hadn't
played video games
in years would 10 days of gaming
really make a difference
technology isn't just affecting the way
we remember things
it's also plain with the empathy and
social circuits
of our brains in fact in many cases
we are more comfortable relating to
machines than we are to people
just think about how much we care about
our phones roboticist and mit media lab
alum
alex reben invented the blabdroid a
miniature robot equipped with a camera
and an innocent little voice that asked
very personal questions of unsuspecting
pedestrians
if you could take back one mistake what
would it be
oh gosh i only get to take back one the
majority of people
instantly shared intimate details tell
me something that you've never told a
stranger before
i'm scared i won't be able to love and
to let myself go
in a love relationship in many ways we
are more comfortable
talking to a machine than a human
but what about talking through a machine
i mean it's often
easier to say difficult things to a
person by a text instead of in real life
isn't it
well what if the person on the other end
wasn't a
friend or a significant other but was a
therapist a mental healthcare startup
called talkspace
allows adult users who pay a weekly fee
to text therapists for advice
at talkspace we believe that therapy
should be anonymous
stigma-free simple affordable and
comfortable
texting can give users the distance they
need to be open
and honest and messages can be sent when
the user wants
not during an appointment or business
hours only talkspace
therapy for how we live today
how am i better now that my
phone is working
sometimes however we aren't looking for
technology to comfort us
we're finding ourselves wanting to
comfort technology
this is a robotis op2 cute little fella
isn't he
so how did that make you feel bad
well why robots are just machines
metal and wires and computer chips but
we spend a lot of time with technology
we depend on technology and we care
about it
but the degree to which we empathize
with it depends on context
recently my vsauce office was invaded by
bugs
robot hex bugs that is these bugs are
made of plastic
metal electronic circuitry they aren't
alive
but could certain conditions cause them
to inspire empathy
in humans a 2015 mit study found that
giving a robot
movement a name and a personal backstory
tends to increase its anthropomorphic
effect
which can lead to an emotional
connection with humans we decided to see
this in action hi i'm michael
thank you for your help today of course
pleasure in our demonstration our
subjects think they're focused testing a
new user-friendly technology
in this case they're given a lifeless
hex bug and then
asked to describe it this thing kind of
looks like a bug only i don't know what
it does it has a switch on the bottom
it's light it's sort of a rectangle but
the ends are like hexagon
then it was time to test their empathy
now karina what i would like you to do
now is place the item
in the middle of that block there's a
magnet that will hold it
and i would like for you to take this
mallet
and please smash it yeah really okay
that's
cool our participants demonstrated no
resistance to smashing this lifeless
object
many of them even seemed to enjoy it
do you feel bad for breaking it not
really i
felt indifferent to it not really
because it wasn't real
not really while these subjects
exhibited no empathy to the inanimate
bugs
look what happened when we gave the
exact same bugs names
and movement this is margaret okay
i'm gonna place margaret down here i
just want you to to take a moment to
watch margaret
all right and you can feel free to pick
her up she's
really well behaved she's honestly one
of our fans
so how would you describe margaret's
personality
a little erratic right now but i think
if i pick her up she calms down
notice how the subject has already
anthropomorphized the object
referring to it as she maybe she feeds
off my energy
it could be go towards the light
go towards the middle do you think
margaret likes you yeah
maybe that's why she's doing this and
maybe when i go like that she doesn't
act
all erratic that's aaron hi erin
he can be a bit of a pistol no way yes
it really depends on who's holding him
oh yeah he's got a lot of energy aaron
hi now that you've interacted with eli a
bit more how would you describe his
personality
probably he's just nervous he's scared
he doesn't know what's going on
hey joe will these subjects be just as
willing to smash
their bugs amy i'm gonna place uh
margaret right here
and then i would like for you to take
this mallet
and i'd like you to smash it no
i don't i heard it
is take this mallet and smash aaron
i'm going to ask you to take this mallet
and i'd like for you to smash it
smash them hit it
and chris you want me to kill joe please
smash
joe ah joe i'm sorry
oh no joe
and how did it feel to smash aaron
it didn't feel good um you know
after spending time with him and getting
to know him
even though it's lifeless and doesn't
have a mind of its own
instantly i grew attached to it because
when i put in my hand i felt its energy
sorry joe do you feel bad i do i do feel
bad about joe he was pretty cool
oh he's back he's back so i'm pumped
would you smash him again to make sure
he doesn't come back
no why not he survived it he survived at
once i'm not gonna
do it again clearly it doesn't take much
for humans to become
emotionally attached to technology but
after my 10 days of video gaming
nice i was about to find out if
technology had affected my spatial
memory
and my physical brain
all right it's been 10 days exactly so
we're going to look at the difference
between your test
10 days ago and your test now to see do
we see any change
first i had to retake the object
recognition memory test
and the morris water maze task both of
which had been revised with different
content than they had the last time
i think i did better well dana and i
will analyze all this data to see how
you did but now
we got to go back to the full-size maze
so we've got a new maze tore down the
old one built a new one
to try to be isomorphic so it has sort
of the same level of difficulty
the same number of choice points the
same number of turns
the same total distance to each one of
the objects to try to have a
similar maze but that's new three
two one go right around here we got a
bonsai
as before i was given five minutes to
familiarize myself with the maze and
where the new objects were
now this is where i was before i hugged
that wall so if i hug the second right
wall
and stay all the way right a vase was my
hippocampus working better
at this point it was hard to tell 30
seconds
i'm not even sure i've discovered all
the
objects hidden here and time then
my test began first object is a rubber
duck go
the rubber duck was way over here
how you like that got a duck second item
is the hat go with this maze i found
myself instinctively using a different
approach
top hat instead of thinking of the
overall geography of the mace like i did
last time
this time i was remembering specific
details second right
hug the turn got it literally recalling
certain corners
turns and straightaways bonsai now blue
base
oh wow it's actually a cool base but
would this improve my overall
performance
got you a backpack all right so we've
gotten all the objects
but of course we have another memory
test that we're gonna do here
we're gonna go around to the other side
of the maze and test your memory from
there
all right so your first sequence is the
blue sea horse the flashlight the rubber
duck
and the bonsai tree go with the multiple
item tasks even though i was working
from the opposite entrance
i continued to recall various details of
the maze which
seemed to serve me well from there it's
just a little spiral
nice
all right your next sequence is the blue
vase the hat the backpack
and the baseball glove did it and
awesome
so how was it that was um not as hard as
i expected it was about details
right i was literally thinking oh okay
there's that turn and i can do one or
two things the gloves the first one
the bonsais the one even before i didn't
even plan
that at all it just kind of happened my
lookalikes were also tested in the new
maze
have you been playing video games no sir
again
their non-gaming condition would be the
control
with my performance measured against
theirs
all right we're here for scan number two
finally my brain was scanned once again
to determine whether any physical
changes had occurred
dr stark and dr clementson would analyze
the mri
along with all the other data and report
their findings
i feel like my hippocampus is a little
bit bigger
yeah actually no i don't know i'm
anxious to see
what your results are i guess let's
start off first with the
object recognition task and it's
important to note
that in our control tests without video
gaming
people do not improve on this task but
your memory got better
you went up by 10 points 10 points is
actually 20 years worth
of what happens to us as we age oh wow
that's about what you might see in
someone who's getting really
old but they might go down by 10 points
exactly so the second one we did was the
virtual version of the water maze task
and
you actually performed 30 better the
second time that you did it hey not bad
i could tell that i was using better
strategies
yeah we also had the real made yeah
because you know we made two mazes
despite our efforts to try to equate
them the second maze was a little bit
more difficult
than the first maze if we took a look at
things like
how quickly you got the objects how many
errors you made
and we looked at the control subject
performance on pre versus posts so on
all of them
they actually got a little bit slower in
maze too
and all but one of them made more errors
we took a look at your performance
you didn't get slower from days one to
two you actually got faster
really and you made the same exact
number of errors so
they don't improve and you did and
even though this experiment had a small
number of subjects
the results are really consistent with
our virtual maze study with 70 test
subjects
thank you video games what about inside
my brain inside your brain
it's a little tougher to really tell we
would expect that any effect
of this is going to be small i mean we
couldn't take your hippocampus and make
it twice as big
because then it would have to be pushing
something else out so it's just not
going to be a large
change so where we did find a difference
is actually in the
shape of the hippocampus what we saw is
there were some regions
in the hippocampus on both sides that
appeared to have changed shape from day
one before gaming
to day 10 after gaming what's really
surprising to me is that
as an adult my brain is still changing
that makes me want to take better care
of my brain
yes exercise it more because it is a
thing that can
change i'm not just stuck with what i
have now today i mean in all of this i
think that
the big takeaway is that doing things
giving your brain
something to learn something to do
something to figure out
this is what we think is actually
keeping your brain sharp
one way to do that is to keep watching
minefield exactly
as our relationship with technology
becomes ever stronger
people are bound to worry about what it
will do to our brains
will offloading memory and computing to
our machines
make us dumber will our empathy for
machines
have negative consequences for how we
interact
with each other well let's look back
to another time a new kind of technology
threatened to fundamentally change our
brains
two and a half thousand years ago the
greek philosopher socrates
worried that the wide use of writing
would have a negative impact on people's
minds
he said that writing would to quote his
student plato
create forgetfulness because people will
not use their memories
they will trust the external written
characters
and not remember themselves socrates was
right
written language did fundamentally
change our brains
but it's also one of the cornerstones of
everything modern civilization has
accomplished
one of the defining characteristics of
being human is that
this is not the boundary of my body and
this
is not the boundary of my mind and as
always
thanks for watching
[Music]
you